shrila is not friendly to women or
minorities or gays I wanted to fix my
country I wanted to trade them I was
banned classic liberals were banned you
can never show fear guess what I say
whatever the heck I want because the
Internet is the worst nightmare for any
dictatorship back in 2006 when Egypt was
ruled by strongmen Hosni Mubarak
Cinthia Farhad co-founded the first
secular classical liberal political
party in the country's modern history
the government reacted by putting Farhad
under continuous surveillance by
intelligence agents and the secret
police and she was later placed on an
al-qaeda affiliates hit list and banned
from entering Lebanon fearing for her
life Farhad sought political asylum in
the u.s. in 2011 and today she's a
writer political analyst and fellow at
the Middle East forum her work has
exposed the secret ties between the
Islamists the military and governments
across the Middle East reasons spoke
with Farah hot about her mission to
bring a true alternative to the region
and why she believes its people are
hungry for civil liberties and free
markets I wanted Liberty and I knew that
the way to get there was through sound
ideas that have proven to work when you
look at American you look at the Soviet
Union you look at Egypt it doesn't take
a brain surgeon to know which
fundamental ideas you need to go with
how did you get put under surveillance
in Egypt so I was under constant 24-hour
surveillance in Egypt for almost a
decade and I knew this in a very
sinister and nasty way I once got these
two daily call me for a 2:00 or 3:00
a.m. every single day for ten years till
this day I wake up at that time
automatically because I'm used to being
woken up at this time one of the times I
said hello
and I heard my own voice on the other
end of the line and it was a recorded
conversation that I had with one of my
best friends in my living room that was
super creepy that's the good phone call
the bad phone calls okay hello in the
middle of the night and some
necrophiliac would be on the other side
of the line and he would start just talk
about the intimate things that he wants
to do to my decapitated
head that he's gonna keep in his freezer
if I don't stop my political work how
would you reply to something like that
and that specific guy is just very
breathe very heavily and I would tell me
and I was so unattractive to women maybe
that's what's causing your women's
issues and I tell them this kind of
stuff because you can't show fear right
you can never show fear I used to
regulate my breathing before I answer
the phone because I never would let them
see me in a state of vulnerability and
you you are a Coptic Christian yes you
grew up a persecuted minority in Egypt
what was that what's that like for the
the cops in Egypt historically and and
today it always goes from bad to worse
because Egypt is a constitutional
theocracy so the rules and the laws are
based on Sharia law and Sharia law is
not friendly to minorities and it does
not provide equal treatment of women or
minorities or gays and also if America
for example does something that they
don't like there's a collective
punishment against God because they're
viewed as Americans are Christians and
you're Christians so they would get
abused every time America did something
that Islamists didn't like but of course
I had Muslim friends who were nothing
like that but they were the minority is
it possible for an Islamic Republic to
have more secular values I guess because
we see you know in a place like Turkey
even 5-10 years ago it was viewed as
this sort of you know as a moderate
Islamic Republic that they respected
people's civil liberties and now in the
last you know a few years it's really
kind of descended more into sort of a
sort of autocratic rule that we see in
Egypt historically so do you think that
that it's possible to maintain those
values of you know even Sharia if you're
if you're a Muslim and you believe in
that but not bring that into the
political sphere so it would not be
Islamic it would be just a secular state
with the majority of citizens Muslims
and we had that before we had a
beautiful constitution in the 20s that
granted absolute freedom of speech and
granted all civil liberties and it was
very very capitalist so that is a
Chiva well but it's but but it's not
achievable in the context of radical
Sunni Islamic theology or radical Shia
Islamic theology you have to have full
separation between mosque and state and
the second thing in regards to Turkey
this is will always be a threat as long
as the Muslim Brotherhood the big
elephant in every single room and every
single discussion about the Middle East
is not designated as a terrorist
organization as long as they're allowed
to operate in any country they always
have subversive activities to destroy it
from within according to their own words
and not my conspiracy theory they talk
about something called a Maliha jihad
jihad area which has civilization jihad
operation which is to destroy countries
and militaries and educational systems
and media from within this group is the
most dangerous group of terrorists
around the world and it needs to be
designated as a terrorist group because
if they were designated a terrorist
group you would not see Aragon in power
today you would not see him know she in
power in Tunisia today you would not
have even seen Gamal Abdul Nasser in
Egypt in 1952 and power and how
specifically do you think that that
would have benefited preventing the rise
of these rulers because like in Egypt
you know the Muslim Brotherhood was
crackdown on for so long it was illegal
until the revolution happened and then
you know bata obviously been organizing
in secret they came out of the woodwork
and they won the first democratic
elections so you know how would
designating it a terrorist organization
sort of help to actually prevent them
from being effective so actually they
were never designated a terrorist group
in Egypt that was the narrative Mubarak
was selling to the West let me tell you
something very interesting the reason I
dismantled my political party was
because Mubarak regime in the Muslim
Brotherhood came hand in hand approached
my party and came hand in hand together
and said we will grant you the official
establishment of the party if you say
that the Muslim Brotherhood are
persecuted in Egypt and that they're not
terrorists
isn't that interesting they had control
of the media of the military and of the
education system if you looked at who
was really banned I was banned classic
liberals were bent people that stand for
what values of freedom and Western
civilization were banned the Muslim
Brotherhood was never been and before
the so-called presidential elections I
published an article intentionally to
say exactly what's going to happen and I
said that there's going to be a Muslim
Brotherhood member installed in power
and he is and then he will be so
horrible and in the military will claim
will come to save the people because
it's like a tango they've been dancing
together since 1952 farah hots
prediction turned out to be correct
after the egyptian revolution out stood
Mubarak in 2011 and paved the way for
the Muslim Brotherhood to win Egypt's
first elections its tenure lasted only
12 months before military General Abdel
Fattah el-sisi stepped in he removed the
Brotherhood's Mohamed Morsi from power
and assumed his place as Egypt's new
strongmen so is the choice always
between a strong autocrat on the one
hand so like you have now with CCM age
of the military leader essentially
versus the Muslim Brotherhood and if
people are going to vote for the Muslim
Brotherhood is that is it preferable to
have these autocrats in power or what
what do you think is the ideal neither
this is the equation they wanted us to
abide by since 1952 it's either us or
the Brotherhood or Isis style we have a
great heritage in classic liberalism in
this country and that is the actual
option and an alternative that the
regime and the brotherhood collaborate
together to destroy if the regime stops
and the Brotherhood used to also do that
when they were briefly in power stop
raping dissidents and stop killing
liberals and stop going after their
families like they went after my brother
there's going to be so much more and
that's where US politics can come in and
say okay we'll cut aid if you continue
to kill your of dissidents who are
speaking for non-violent and very
tolerant ideas going back to Assisi are
you in favor of the US sort
propping him up because he is a force
that counteracts the Islamists or is it
just we should not be involved
regardless they really need to get out
of this business not prop him up and not
try to destroy him because these regimes
would crumble by their own device of
their left on their own they have the
they have the internal mechanisms to
self-destruct
like any tyranny but as long as we're
giving them arms as long as we're giving
them aid you will never see reform but
the but there's a very important point
as well that the Muslim Brotherhood and
terrorists has such our common enemy so
I believe in some collaboration it's
sort of a longer term struggle to win
hearts and minds and change people
change people's views especially when
dissidents are getting tortured or put
in jail but if in the immediate term you
know the the choice is between allowing
people to vote in a democratic election
and perhaps they choose the Islamists
right if that's the current status quo
what do we do I don't believe in
democracy I believe in the rule of law
I believe in Republic I don't believe in
the mob rule because soon the ballot box
turns into a guillotine and that is a
very very dangerous recipe I would never
endorse if they vote that oh we all want
to kill you because you have red hair am
I going to support it because it's the
democracy and majority I don't believe
in that that's illegitimate it's only
legitimate when it's the rule of law
there's an argument that sort of you
know a lot of Middle Eastern countries
are simply not ready for democracy right
they need a strong man or an autocrat in
order to keep things in line to prevent
you know massive violence all these
different factions fighting each other
do you agree with that I absolutely do
not agree with that because I have been
in the political process myself and I've
seen it and I've seen how people were
hungry for our ideas I had veiled women
hugging me and crying and begging me to
continue fighting for for the freedom of
thought and freedom of religion and to
protect them from the Muslim Brotherhood
I believe that Egyptians are very ready
for freedom and if it wasn't for a
blasphemy laws by the way you would see
so many more of them and that's what
ultimately got you in trouble right
of course do you think that it's
possible that what we've seen happen in
Syria could play out in Egypt could play
out anywhere in the Middle East if you
if the Muslim Brotherhood has its way
that's what exactly what would happen
they they they're calling every day if
you look at their websites they're
calling for something similar every day
they declared against against regular
Muslims and Christians something called
total fear in a fear I am which is total
war that's why they need to be
designated a terrorist organization if
they have enough funding to start to
fund military and recruit military
operations inside the country yes yes we
will see a scenario similar to Syria and
do you think that there is a sort of a
lasting legacy of the Arab Spring that's
something positive going forward and you
know do you think it's possible that
there could actually be a secular free
market-based
governance in the Middle East absolutely
yes because let me tell you something
about the Arab Spring that started in
1998 the internet under Mubarak regime
it was illegal for 4-5 people to sit in
a room and discuss politics under
emergency law because the government
would basically come or rape you or kill
you or you just disappear and vanish
from the face of the earth and the
internet allowed us peaceful assembly
for the first time since 1952 and if you
go the war of ideas you will find every
economic school is debated every form of
government is debated in Arabic every
religious sect
there's no blasphemy laws on the
internet thankfully let's hope
Zuckerberg doesn't start to implement it
because I think he wants to so because
the Internet is the worst nightmare for
any dictatorship and let me give you
another example I was banned from my
name was banned from mention from being
mentioned in the paper from 2006 late
2006 till 20 2015 2015 I started
publishing in Arabic and one of the most
important newspapers
and guess what I publish articles with
zero censorship I say whatever the heck
I want and I'm only getting positive
feedback for my values so I'm definitely
optimistic so you think if we just kind
of stripped away some of those layers of
the blasphemy laws and the support for
these dictators there is sort of a
hunger for these types of ideas and it
exists and they're very powerful
organizations that emerged right now and
it's a very very rich intellectual
atmosphere that developed over there so
I'm very excited about I'm very happy
great well thank you so much for talking
with us today my pleasure thank you for
having me for reason I'm Justin
Monticello
[Music]
you
[Music]